so
how is nimona
[Music]
oh
all right
first of all
I will warn you before I get into full
spoilers on this this is going to be
partly a review but this is going to be
me mostly talking about
just how amazing this movie is through a
pretty specific lens but unlike
when I talked about across the spider
verse where the degree to which I took a
queer and explicitly trans reading of
that movie is debatable as to how much
it was intended or maybe most
appropriate uh nimona is a movie that is
explicitly gay
intrinsically trans and yeah I'm gonna
be running with that but I'll give you a
warning before I get into spoilers
because we are going to do those
but nimona is a animated film now
available on Netflix it actually was
originally being done by Blue Sky
animation the folks who did uh the Ice
Age movies
which was owned by Fox
and they were mostly done with the movie
uh then Disney bought Fox and blue sky
animation came with it and Disney
shut them down instead of letting them
finish the movie
thankfully Disney did allow Netflix to
come in and buy the rights and the work
that had already been done so that they
could then bring on a team to finish up
the work and now release the film
pneumonia is something I've known about
for a while because I've read the
graphic novel well I say graphic novel
it started out as a webcomic by ND
Stevenson
and you might be familiar with his work
elsewhere as he was the main creative
force behind Shira and the princesses of
power
now uh Andy Stevenson is trans Bali I
believe currently identifying as
masculine non-binary
um he is now using he him pronouns I did
check that
um before starting to do this uh he'll
sometimes go by Nate
um but generally credited as ND
Stevenson
and nemoda was effectively what got his
entire career started nimona began as a
web comic
and it just developed its story over
time and that story was eventually
collected as a graphic novel now if
you've never read the graphic novel you
should even if you've already seen the
movie The Heart and core of it is very
much there but I would really really
recommend that even if you've seen the
movie don't think you've had The Full
Experience go and read the graphic novel
as well there's a rawness to it an
unpolished feel to it that's actually
part of its appeal and in a way even
kind of contributes to how it develops
because as I said Stevenson was working
on this from a young age and continue to
work on it as he became better as an
artist and the result of that is the
earlier parts of that graphic novel when
it's all collected because this was done
over years
you read it and it starts out much
simpler not a lot of backgrounds pretty
Bare Bones and while maintaining that
same core art style as the story
progresses and the scale and scope of
the story grows the artwork also becomes
more uh intricate more backgrounds just
more going on and more refined and it
actually complements the storytelling
this was kind of a happy accident but
all right in short go read it it's great
so
pneumonia
the film
is an excellent adaptation it's a
fantastic movie
whether you've read the original or not
it's really good you should see it and
it is
the queer movie we really need right now
at a time when animated features
especially those aimed at a family
audience and this is rated PG
at a time when they
do koi little dances
around gender identities sexuality and
even when it's there it's handled in a
very kid-friendly way you know you can
look at something like strange world uh
which did handle its uh gay young
character fairly well but you know it's
basically a teenage crush it just
happens to be on a boy there isn't a lot
that goes into that ultimately there's
something like spider verse that has a
heck of a lot that is allegorically
trans or at least can be read that way
but also is not explicitly so
as I said this is this film has
characters who are explicitly game more
than that
they're adults
they're not children with crushes
they're adults with complicated
relationships
and then there's nimona herself
who is the embodiment
of gender fluidity non-binary
transgender mess can you just be
please I don't follow
go
but I'm not a girl I'm a shark
she is that and I don't even really mean
that metaphorically because Stevenson
has been pretty overt about the fact
that working on pneumonia
and working on that character was a way
to Channel A lot of his own confusion
and uncertainty
I didn't know what I was doing when I
first started drawing Comics over a
decade ago I just knew that my emotions
were too big for my body and I had to
put them somewhere from these feelings a
character began to emerge I named her
nimona for no particular reason it just
felt right I didn't think I deserved
love but maybe she did
the movie's great even if like you can't
pretend that
um two of the characters are not
explicitly gay like they kiss they're
gay you can't pretend that isn't there
if you chew s to not engage with the
gender aspect of nimona and the trans
and queer and gender fluid and
non-binary nature of her you don't have
to it's still a good movie
but boy does that layer
mean a lot
and to pretend that it isn't there
you're really selling yourself short I
am going to start to go into more detail
and I am going to start to go into
spoilers so if you have not yet seen
this movie
go do it
right now
I like now
if you have access to Netflix go watch
it this video will be here when you're
done
all right so if you're still here
you've either already seen it
or you don't care which is a shame
but I Can't Make You Care
so
let's start with the fact that we never
get a firm answer
to what pneumonia is where she comes
from whether something happened to her
that allowed her to do her
shape-shifting abilities whether she was
always able to do them whether something
happened and we don't know what her
quote unquote true form is one minute
shift you don't want me to shift pick
away and now you're a boy I am today and
we shouldn't
they are all
her
every shape and every form she takes is
who she is none of it's fake it's just a
different part of her and I love
that when she is asked what are you she
only ever has one answer
are you
I'm pneumonia that's the only answer
anybody should ever have to give
I'm me
the specifics beyond that firstly not
really your business secondly
is your perception of me
as a being worthy of respect
empathy interacting with is it
contingent on the answer to that
because if it is then I definitely don't
want you to have the answer and if it's
not you shouldn't be asking people don't
just turn into things I do okay fine
well then I have a million questions
you get one
it's great
it is it is perfect and this really
holds true to the core of who na Mona is
from the beginning
the shape shifting
or does it
sorry small-minded question
I feel worse when I don't do it like my
insides are itchy then I shape shift
and I'm free what if you held it in I'd
Die Oh Glory that's horrible I wouldn't
die die I just sure wouldn't be living
and
there's some things that I think are
really worth pointing out especially put
through a queer lens and especially
especially with everything going on now
because
baluster the
villain that she becomes the sidekick to
she hooks up with him because
he has been basically framed for
something he is the most wanted person
in this Kingdom and so to her I oh
someone who's just as hated as me why
are you helping me
because I'm bored
and everybody hates you too
now it's interesting to me that while
she is very much operating on a level
with a lot of anger
uh not unjustified anger given how the
world treats her given that this world
is literally built on a foundation of
hating her
given that her anger is pretty
understandable but you know what's
interesting
despite the fact that she jokes about
killing people very casually
she never does
she has the opportunity
and she'll draw like her little artwork
of running people through was the Rhino
or whatever
when she actually is the Rhino she
knocks people out of the way she could
like she does a ton of damage ton of
Destruction she wants to cause chaos but
she has plenty of opportunity to kill
people and doesn't
because ultimately
for as angry as she is and as hurt as
she is
what she really wants is to not be alone
and again it's worth noting that anger
is not unjustified
and if you're going to take a character
like baluster who he and nimona have
similar goals why would I trust you
because if you don't you're gonna die in
this closet but he very much takes a
position of look we're going to do this
quietly we're not going to make a fuss
you could make a very easy comparison to
a certain kind of queer person or even
queer advocate
the kind who says the more in your face
stuff
The Pride parades with drag queens and
people in assless chaps that's too much
can you please just be normal for a
second normal I just think it'll be
easier if you're a goat easier to be a
girl
you're hilarious you should go low-key
go unnoticed
that's how we can affect change I mean
these are if you look human easier for
who and on the one hand you could make
the argument that pneumona represents
a younger and more raucous generation of
queer people but that's only going by
the visual coding
because the reality is pneumonia is
older than baluster
a lot older
she's always been here
just as we have always been here
and she
has no problem
causing a scene
causing I don't know
a riot
people need to remember
now and always and forever
that pride and the Gay Liberation
movement as we know it started at
Stonewall as a riot
so anyone who says we should be
politely working within the system
has forgotten their own history
of why
gay pride Gay Liberation and gay rights
and queer rights trans rights all of
them are necessary
and I think baluster really works to at
least initially
embody a form of queer that is
content to just or thinks that the way
to go about this is
more low-key a lot of people aren't as
accepting as me
heck when he finds out that the director
of this group that he he had worked so
hard to be a part of is behind what has
gone on his only goal initially is to
take her down the institute's not the
problem the director is
he thinks the system that's in place is
fine if he just removes the Bad Apple
the system is what's broken
maybe certain people within that system
are making it worse are the embodiment
of the worst of what that system is but
the system itself
is not functioning in a way that should
be allowed to continue I will not be
quiet about this this video could damage
people's Faith In The Institute
especially on the foundation has been
built on of demonizing
people like nimona
as monsters
and that's something baluster has to
learn
and even beyond that the way that they
try to expose the director
and the way that she's just able to turn
all that around right back on them it
could be anyone
spouse your child your best friend the
person sitting next to you
none of us are safe
the fact that she has the Cannons that
point out and away from the city and
over the wall turned into the city
do you think happens
when these restrictions are made of
queer lives of trans lives we are
already seeing we are seeing CIS gender
women harassed out of bathrooms because
they look less feminine quote unquote
than others we see children yelled at at
track meets with adults saying that
their genitals should be inspected to
confirm what gender they are
because these people
have bought into the hatred of the
monsters so much that if they can take
us out they don't care who else goes
down
and that frankly goes beyond queer
rights it's the same with Reproductive
Rights and the restrictions going on
with abortions they don't care
that people will die because their lives
would have been saved by a procedure
that is now being outlawed
that
children are being forced to carry
Offspring to term
they don't care about the collateral
damage and that is made literal in this
and I do not think that it is
coincidental or if it is boy does it
feed into everything the fact that
baluster
is a CIS gay man and with all due
respect going by the statistics and
recent history CIS gay men are the part
of the queer community that has appeared
to be most likely to ignore the plight
of the others or even throw us under the
bus you are using me you wanted them to
see a villain someone else to hate so
you wouldn't be alone
although I do find it interesting to
note that neither baluster nor Ambrosius
are white meanwhile Todd the worst very
much is did you think I was gonna
[Music]
the director
the director is also really interesting
to talk about because she shows the
intersectionality of bigotry she
initially frames baluster because she
sees someone of lower status of lower
class achieving what he is about to
achieve as quote the first crack in the
wall allowing baluster to hold the sword
was the first crack in the wall any
disruption of the status quo she
believes it should be will result in a
flood of everything she hates being
allowed can't you see this is what it
wants for us to let our guard down this
is the purpose of hateful legislation to
clamp down on oppressed people now
before they get a foothold before there
is a single crack in the wall that's why
you can't just exist alongside them that
would be allowing the men that would be
allowing the crack to go unsealed
and the crack grows bigger and bigger
her position her beliefs and her
language feel very carefully chosen to
me and this is in opposition to what
baluster will ultimately learn that the
wall is only keeping out
people
he learns
as does
Ambrosius that monster is a threat to a
very way of life and what if we're wrong
what if we've always been wrong
so
don't take it as a condemnation
don't take it as a lack of Hope
they do learn
and they realize the system that needs
to be dismantled
if things are ever
going to be okay
lessons need to be unlearned ways of
raising children to view others and
condemn a certain kind of person need to
be unlearned
and all of that is here
and it's not even subtext
it's textual
it's right there
I would have given anything
I have a story like this when I was
young
but I'm glad it's here now
because nimona
embodies
The Pride
the joy
the anger
the sadness
the hopelessness
and the power of somebody reaching out
and touching your heart literally in the
case of this movie he literally touches
her heart
the power of that is all in here
and it's fun and it's funny and it's
raucous and it's entertaining and it's
wonderful to look at the voice acting is
great and the soundtrack just kicks ass
foreign
this movie
especially knowing that we almost didn't
get it
this movie is a miracle
and I can't be thankful enough
to the animators to the directors to the
studios that saved it
most of all
to Andy Stevenson
forgiving this story
and for
letting it be on the biggest platform
it's ever had
and I hope that everyone who should see
it does
and for the record that's most people
thank you for listening
I had to talk about why this is such an
amazing movie to me
what did you think about nimona
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living
but even if you can't help me out that
way there's links to other things I do
in the description
like share subscribe you know what the
things are but what
what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
foreign
[Music]